hey guys welcome back to gamescom 2015
i'm here with PETA so you just seen some
halo 5 guardians yeah 3 for 3 studios in
Microsoft were showing off some of the
the single-player stuff and as you know
in halo 5 Guardians you are playing as
master chief or lock but you're always
sort of rolling with a team it's been
confirmed now that you never actually
plays solo so the team thing is pretty
important and this allows you to do some
co-op stuff but what they were showing
today was sort of how you command the
team to use them in a few that's
interesting because previously it was
you be just Master Chief you were this
big guy against all the elites all the
Brutes all the grunts but now you've got
a squad at go back how is that going to
affect the way you play so a master
chief sort of takes on the role of a
commander now in some instances he's
still in the fray he's still shooting
and fighting but not always so there was
one instance where a room serve had two
levels there was the ground level in the
upper level so master chief told his his
crewmates say okay you guys go down
below I'm gonna take the top so while
they were down fighting all the little
guys Master Chief was sort of providing
support fire cover fire and that gave
him an opportunity to sort of take his
time and observe the situation which is
kind of interesting and he was also able
to instruct the team to say pick up
certain weapons right so rather than
pick it up himself he could have someone
else pick it up which is which is good
because I don't know if the AI would
really be able to negotiate the priority
of who gets what and beyond that you
have the simple thing where you can
assaulted tahay attack that enemy if you
want that's interesting because I mean
the only real teams are not that we saw
was when they did ODST yeah and that was
really commanding you were just a part
of a group and you weren't Spartans you
weren't the all-powerful you just dues
yeah but do you think they're trying to
take focus away from Master Chief
because now that it's their baby 343
have this it feels like they're
experimenting with new things with each
new halo game they're bringing out
dresses it's another experiment in the
same direction I mean they do have sort
of a you know a broader scope in terms
of who matters in the story but they
also showed a silhouette of Cortana
interesting yeah so it sounds like she
or something like her
maybe it's a mimic or you know she's
been assimilated by it by something else
will play a part in the story and when
Master Chief's saw her you could kind of
tell it was that moment when the two
characters were at least he felt that
connection right that it always sort of
takes him out of the adventure of the
mission at hand he's very focused on her
so I think it's still Master Chief story
but there's definitely a lot more going
on and that's not the only thing
pertaining to the clock well that's good
that they're trying to keep it connected
to the hailer world because well five
games in following Master Chief it's
gonna be hard for guys to really keep
invested in something that's gone from
the original xbox now it's xbox one but
from what you told me the campaign's a
lot longer and they're offering a lot
more in terms of content yeah they said
it's going to be twice as long as halo 4
so but they've also mentioned that they
are making your biggest investment in
multiplayer that they've ever made
before and I asked them how do those two
things work together how do you invest
so much a multiplayer to make a campaign
twice as long and all I didn't really
get the best answer there saying oh this
individual teams or individual things
you know they're making a much larger
game than they have in the past so
there's going to be a lot more halo
content for people Kazumi 20 maps at
launch which sounds like a lot of you
yeah and then in the eight weeks that
follow they're going to be adding more
for free all new content DLC is going to
be free because they don't really want
to leave people out of the experience I
don't want to feel like they beating off
fine absolutely well I know you're the
one that saw it but for me hearing you
talk about it feels like this is three
four freeze kind of Hail Mary cancer
halo nothing halo 4 did as well as in
one of the two so now they're like okay
everything halo five let's do this but
Rotom it's gonna be really interesting
to see what comes off when it comes out
but for your halo 5 news and put
everything from gamescom 2015 keep it
tuned in for gamespot
you